you
three
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
to you by the way we have a special
friend with us today i call him the
greatest barber in the world
aka philosopher also known as
michael rapatoni michael thank you for
being a guest
here with us on the podcast thank you
for having me you can't see the hair but
if you look at that hair that's the hair
that's the hair that my son is last
night my son is doing his uh
he's blow-drying his own hair he says
dad look i got
michael's hair kill for that by the way
shout out to dylan dylan finally
tied his own shoelaces before his
brother did at six years old and he was
all ecstatic about it and we have a
adam we learned something about adam
this morning just so everybody knows
uh so you guys know how we were
concerned about why adam keeps going to
the bathroom everybody's wondering what
is really going on does he have to use
about like even right now he just when
he came back yeah yeah yeah so what
happened was kai
was in their monitoring because we
wanted to see what was really the
intention yeah he found
he goes into the bathroom to throw up
before the podcast so that's
that's kind of what it is yeah we now
know now you would see
based on my my looks you think it's
bulimia it's just nerves it's sitting
next to rapid tony right here
it's just nerves so by the way the first
second i walked in i go damn josh looks
good
but it's rapid tony okay it's rapid tony
today we all have white shirts on it's
white your tuesday
uh minus your uh blue jeans uh whatever
you got on i can take it off
it's it's it's an environment where we
forgive people so it's fine all right
folks if you're getting on
we are getting on a little earlier we
did say it's gonna start at eight
o'clock but we got on at 7 45 so we got
12 minutes till 8.
for those of you that are troopers and
you're on put put up the thumbs button
if you can
and share this and let's get the podcast
started we got a lot of things to talk
about obviously the rnc
happened yesterday i watched every one
of the speeches last night till midnight
so i got some thoughts on that i got an
fda warning that i didn't even tell you
about
from fda telling you you should stop
eating this one fruit
that is not good for you and it's it's
very interesting what this fruit is
you know a part of this fruit i think
you like there's a there's an
element of this fruit that i have a
feeling adam i'm excited to hear with
this i'm gonna tell you what this fruit
is i like how you don't tell
we have we have notes we prep yeah yeah
yeah but pat keeps something under a
scene yeah at all times
so this one's an interesting one and we
got to talk about lebron james and
what he said to trump about goodyear
tires and what happened there with
superman showing up out of nowhere we'll
talk about that
but we'll talk about tesla tesla and
walmart maybe we'll go into that story
first
toys r us after being put out of
business
toys r us decides to go back to an old
partner old friend that put him out of
business and we're gonna see if that's
gonna work out or not
uh toy source and amazon possibly
starting a relationship together again
and then norway man these people from
norway you gotta be careful with them
okay
their capitalists they want to make
money they have seven trillion dollars
of reserves and oil
but they also believe in climate change
yeah like tremendously they believe in
climate change people can't spell for
very good great people cannot spell for
[ __ ] and by the way
searching sometimes searching on google
yeah forever they got to teach a class
in high school and it's how to search
properly on google
and then we have let's see here are
republicans or democrats better for
economy
kellyanne conway stepped away i have a
special simpsons video i want to show
you which is classic simpsons video some
shooting that happened in wisconsin
tragic event tick tock
sues the us government and then a couple
other events but let's get first
into the future of tesla okay so check
this out so
tesla announces they're they're doing a
split okay
five to one split their share closes
thursday uh
last week at two thousand dollars give
or take okay they're up
you know six point five six percent in
one day
for the year they're up three hundred
and eighty percent
for the year i'm not talking about two
years three years they're up 380
for the year in seven and a half months
okay
so to all the people that listen to the
scene i wish i would have put some money
into tesla
if you would have put a hundred thousand
dollars into tesla you now have
three hundred and eighty thousand
dollars two hundred and eighty thousand
dollars is what you have depending on
how they do the math 380 right
if you would have put a hundred thousand
beginning of the year so they're
crushing it
but news just came out that tesla
is officially worth more than walmart
tesla is now worth 371 billion dollars
walmart is now worth 370 billion dollars
here's the difference
tesla's revenues is only 25 billion
walmart's revenue
is 523 billion how is tesla's revenue
20 times less than walmart but they're
worth
more than walmart what do you say to
that man that's crazy stuff right to
think about
you know the i i don't have like the
mathematical approach to this but i will
give a metaphor right
so we've all been to high school we've
been to college you know we're dudes
here we
we like hot chicks you know there's
girls that we you know we're into
and then the new girl shows up and
you're like damn bro you see the damn
like oh like she's then she it's like
the the new hot girl right and all of a
sudden you forget that like all the
girls you were into before in school you
know
uh they kind of are you know they oh you
know they're
you know been there done walmart being
in school though who would walmart be in
school
who would she be the who would she be
she would be like you know the captain
of the cheerleading team that's been
around on the team for a handful of
years
you know people are over if you've seen
mean girls you know she'd be the
like this is a good mean girls uh
analogy she'd be um
i don't know a lot of men that watch
mean girls all right i mean listen
great movie i don't know if you guys
seen this yeah but uh amy adams
character i forget is it amy adams
come on guys just so you know no one
here has watched me and girl but tell us
about it tell us about it
lindsay lohan's character shows up and
she's the new girl okay
and all of a sudden the people are like
damn what's up what's up
that's tesla okay she doesn't have the
trash is lindsay lohan it's the new meat
it's a new fresh meat that's what i'm
saying she doesn't have
she doesn't have the track record she
doesn't have the numbers colluded to
prove it you know you got walmart big
beautiful over there being like what's
up you forget about me i'm chop liver
that's tesla now what i will say it
sounds like i'm talking trash
about tesla i'm not she is a hot girl or
in this case a very
if she's somebody mary or she someone
should just have a good weekend with
good fling with
i mean you test it out test drive it
tesla
and then you see what you got but the
thing with that at this point of the
game
plenty of people have test-driven tesla
what i'm saying i don't see that many
teslas on the road
do you i see a handful by the way toyota
forgive adam this is coming from
somebody that doesn't drive for a living
suvs everything i've never been picked
up with a tesla but
um the one thing we forget about tesla
is obviously the
the numbers don't are nowhere near
walmart's numbers the one thing we
forget about tesla is they are not a car
company what are they
they're a tech company yeah people
forget about that what are you talking
about car company they have nowhere near
the revenue or the amount of cars on the
road that a toyota does as an example
but they're a tech company as our good
friend josh would point out
it's all about the data so they're doing
some amazing things over there they're
definitely the new
hot chick on the block yeah but i like
the way you put it
but the only difference is you talk
about 371 billion dollars versus 370
michael what do you say about this
evaluation
this valuation they're getting and
they're 20 times smaller revenue than
walmart
no man i i it's uh you know i love the
technical side of it i think that's
where a lot of the values come in but
and and i love this analogy and and i
think we might find out that that hot
girl
is not going to be so hot you know that
that hot girl does come to it
because you're going to find out she's
got like bad breath or something like
that yeah she's just going to be like
everybody else and you know
it's it's the big game in the beginning
and all of a sudden it falls off
so we're going to see what's going on
i'm on a uh i i had an event at breakers
a couple weeks ago okay so i brought uh
one of my investors
shout out to greg sharer we're sitting
there together and
you know he says uh you have to realize
a company
two companies doing a hundred million
dollars a year one doing 40
a year the other one doing 10 a year
when you decide to sell
either one of these companies the
company doing 40
versus 10 is worth twice as much
as a 10 let me say this one more time
both companies same size
same top line revenue one has grown at a
rate the other one has grown at a 40
rate to sell the company this one may
sell
for 150 million but this one's going to
sell for 300
million okay so it's the percentage of
growth
and if tesla can continue to grow
at this pace like this the market is
saying
long term they're eventually going to
pass walmart that's kind of what they're
saying
they're going to eventually pass walmart
now that's that's it i got to take the
shirt off 380 percent
and by the way if you see stains on his
shirt he was drinking some soy milk
double soy lattes all over myself all
over him so again for the early birds
that you're on with us 7
56 we got four uh more minutes until we
get into eight o'clock
press the thumbs up and uh give a shout
out to michael rapitoni my barber
uh a philosopher he's got a lot of great
opinions and
things he shares every time i go to get
a haircut with him he's either watching
godfather
or he's watching uh uh he's watching
rocky and by the way tell us how this
whole grand opening you opened up you
used to be at floyd's
now you got your own shop from plano i
was i was at finley's i'm sorry phillies
i was at finley's for uh for five years
and i just had an opportunity to come by
i mean it wasn't the uh
uh you know i wasn't thinking you know
pandemic i wasn't thinking i mean we're
talking about
barbershops they've been around since
the beginning of time you know and now
why do you open it right across from
another guy that's been there for
51 years like literally i'm getting a
haircut i look to my right
this the barber shop 51 years across the
street and he stands there
you know mad dog in this gets an
interesting dynamic we talk about that
the power of competition what this guy's
thinking
i you know it's it's uh one i never
thought about it
i knew he was there you know and i just
never thought of it
as competition i mean you know damn
you're just looking right past this guy
i don't
see you exactly yeah i mean you know and
the fact of the matter is i mean just
mathematically it makes sense i mean you
know he's a one-man operation and i've
got three chairs so we got four chairs
in this
gigantic he's a one-man shop one-man
shop okay you know
family that passed down from pops right
right so you know i mean he's got his
customer base i've got a customer base
and we do
we do and sell two different things i
mean he sells haircuts i sell an
experience
you know along with a haircut and uh you
know we hope to do a a good job over
there and the fact is this
we've got four chairs in a very
populated area
um i came from eight chairs under one
roof you know so
i i never looked at my co-workers as
competitors what was the name of the
shop you went to
before finley's finley like ken finley
yeah yeah families
finley's minus jail time we would have
shown him but he has no gel today
and here's a crazy thing here's a crazy
thing for some of you guys that are
listening to this
most people that open up a business they
think well let me beat my competitor in
price
here's the truth about price how much
are the haircuts that your
competitors place yeah they're half what
happens they're 18
what are yours 35. think about this so
not only am i coming across the street
and opening up shop
i'm going to double the price you charge
and i'm still gonna beat you
that that's that's blue ocean at the
highest level if you think about it
yeah it's uh yeah you know it's it's i
do what i do and
and i think that you when you find your
own worth you know um
you wash the hair you do the massage
yeah it's a i mean we you know we offer
such a high level of service i mean you
know
and i think that's why uh so many people
will follow and keep coming
and and our customer base is so strong
you know uh
you know and again coming from finley's
was uh
finley's was the best time of my life
yeah you know i mean it was it was five
years of
the best time that's where you and i got
it connected yeah right right and uh
you know and and i learned a lot and and
decided it was uh
you know you get to a point and i was
going to open and i looked at a lot of
different places
storefronts this is a street which is
really cool
um you know the prices the price points
of rent and all that other stuff yeah
starting a business like that uh but it
was really just came down to opportunity
that's exactly let me ask you you know
one thing about barbers a good barber's
a
psychologist right because barbara sit
there and they're they're asking
questions how's the wife ask the family
how's the kids how is this how is that
in
michael's uh uh clientele they love him
okay they absolutely love him
tell us a crazy story you've had in the
last week or two give us a crazy story
well i i have 35 therapy it's fantastic
give us a great give us a good story
it's cheap right yeah yeah i have i've
had two this week that we're
we're kind of interesting um so real
quick one i'll give you both
okay real quick one yesterday a guy came
in don't name no names repertoire
no and i hope this guy sees this because
it was actually kind of entertaining so
we were there yesterday and he comes in
it was just a walk-in he got off google
or whatever and
and he came in he said listen man he
said here's my problem
my wife just had a baby and my hair
looks bad
and uh you know i'm just trying to get
some
he said this he said that i said my wife
just had a baby
get in the chair i'm trying to get not
only do we need to do a haircut what a
great opening
we need to have a conversation too you
know
let's talk about this so we get them all
fixed up great story night ends last
night i go i get
i get an email from google google gives
there's a review on there
it says unbelievable small place great
time great conversation
cold drinks um thank you for the great
haircut i think i'm going to have my
second kid
so it was uh it's cold that was stored
that was kind of neat
that's quick turn around but the nice
thing about uh
we had a guy come in just the other day
he actually came in because he's a
follower of
he's a a follower of of of you
uh loves you you're his mentor and he
follows every word you say
and he comes in he wants to get his hair
cut where patrick gets his haircut
because okay and this is the second
that's the second time it's not uncommon
you know
and um so he sits in the chair and he
says so how'd you hear about us he said
well
he said it's kind of odd i said i said
i've been following this guy for a
really long time
and uh he he gets this haircut here so
okay what's his name he says patrick bet
david
i said oh patrick's is a good friend he
says
he goes uh i uh i i'm his future
employee
he says i'm gonna work for him and i
said oh okay i said good
does he know he says no he doesn't know
and i said okay i mean that's a normal
question right sure so uh
so i said i said well maybe you should
let him know
i'm going to when i'm ready and i said
all right i said well
you know you need to buy a car you need
how are you gonna ready for what you
know
he's like i just have to get my my life
together i need to get better at what i
do and i need to
so i told her i told him a story about
floyd's i was a so i was
a powerful story if you guys are
listening we briefly touched this
yesterday yeah yeah
so this is not a barbershop store this
is actually a great story so listen up
yeah this is a powerful
valuetainers and and this is what i love
about barbary because this happens on a
daily basis
so guy sits there you know i said to
myself brother i said let me tell you a
story about getting ready i said i i
went to beauty school i wanted to be a
barber i wanted to
i wanted to cut hair i wanted to be a
part of this whole game and i and i sat
and i waited till i was ready
then i go out barber shops weren't
barber shops back then yeah i mean this
is a new thing
last five years barbershop's been
popping up and uh so when i started it
was beauty shop so you're sitting in a
beauty shop and you want to be the guy
and
you uh you want to get to that next
level
so i went to get a haircut at floyd's 99
out in la
i walked in and i said this is the place
this is the place that i want to work
this is this is heaven we got the music
going the atmosphere was right it was
absolutely amazing then i get a good
haircut
i'm under the assumption that all the
haircuts are that way yeah so i decide
that i need to become the best men's
cutter
alive before i apply for the job
at floyd's so i spend three years doing
10 and 12
haircuts making very little eating top
ramen and rice and
you know on a good day once a week maybe
twice a week you go and buy like a steak
or like just a little hamburger and act
like it's a steak you know
yeah you know and i'm wearing money and
i'm working and i'm working and i'm
working because i want to
every cut i'm like i'm one cut closer to
floyd's five thousand cuts
that's the goal getting to the getting
to floyd yeah yeah yeah so i want to get
two three years they're eating top ramen
just preparing for floyds oh no cable tv
no internet i was i'm telling you i was
like like a caveman
and uh so i go so i go i finally say you
know what i'm ready
first of all i'm tired of being broke
second i think i'm ready enough i'm not
ready maybe i got to get out of the
business maybe i need to change all
together
so i go and i apply floyd's instantly
get the job
my first day i wear my greatest outfit
i'm all excited i went and got new shoes
the whole thing
i'd do a haircut and i'm like man i'm in
the big leagues
this is it i made it to florida yeah i
snapped that cape off after my first cut
it's a beautiful haircut i turned let's
see who's looking
and i looked next to me they're done a
haircut too is one of the worst haircuts
i've ever seen
i turn over to the other one and i look
and i'm like wow that's a bad haircut
too
the moral to the story is i was ready
the whole time
i was ready when i was awful you know
so i told this guy why are you telling
yourself whether you're ready or not
that you don't make the final decision
anyway you know so
go and find out if you're ready and if
you're not
don't be afraid to ask the question can
can i come back
when you feel that i'm more ready or or
can you tell me what to do to get ready
for this
and it was beautiful i mean the guy you
know ends up with a
you know decent haircut he loved it and
and he left and he actually bought a
rapid tony's barber shop oh he did so
the five dollar off you buy this shirt
for 20 bucks every time you get a
haircut warning that you get five bucks
that's right that's right now the
question is that a lot of the single men
are listening did he get laid last night
yeah i don't know
because that's the thing the other one
is his wife pregnant gives birth we're
wondering if this guy did or not
yeah how long after giving birth
can you bang your wife what's the rule
of thumb on that six
six weeks is that the number yeah
louise's wife is pregnant he knows the
number i don't know i think that
has been broken before i don't i think
someone i don't know i think we can go
down a slippery slope on this
conversation right here
like but wife is pregnant can you still
have sex is there a rule on that i mean
you know like
it depends on what three months okay but
six months eight months i don't know
about that
some women heal fast once eight months
you can't do that six months what do you
mean six months
while she's six months pregnant i'm
saying during while she's pregnant
you're gonna have you can have sex the
last
day if you want really
[Laughter]
hey sorry buddy jesus you know we had a
friend in high school i can't even save
them because he'll be embarrassed we
have we had a friend
and he had this red patch on his
forehead not india it was terrible no no
massive like red uh what do you call it
like it's almost like uh you know
you have marks uh red uh red marks and
what do you call it like like a
birthmark like gorbachev on top of a
market and everybody shout out to mecca
algorithm everybody used to say when you
when your mom was nine months pregnant
your dad was pounding you in the
forehead
that story stuck from 14 years old
hey man anyways hey so that's that's
michael wright
but getting back to rappatoni's story
and this is what i wanted to give to all
the entrepreneurs out there
is a couple of themes because that is a
very poignant story it's not just about
being a barber it's
number one just get started right i mean
stop
overthinking stop over analyzing you're
gonna start cutting hair just start
you know start cutting some friend you
know and then also done beats perfect
you ever heard that before yeah
dunbee's perfect if you're gonna wait
for the perfect moment to the weight do
you got the scissors in the cut
you could be waiting forever just get
just get started get done beats perfect
and that's
you know and i and i finished him with
with the fact is
you know i i wasted three years trying
to get ready to
for my career three years for that
moment yeah
but perfection perfection i didn't
practice
perfect yeah i didn't babysit children i
didn't change any diapers i didn't
warm up a bottle before my baby was born
you know i brought a human life into the
world
and i didn't get ready you know what i
mean it was just kind of one of those
things that you kind of naturally do
so it's like if you're going to inspire
you though and take your time one of
these days
yeah so he's right many of the things
you do in your life they don't come with
a man you just got to man up and go out
there and get it done so
very good story thanks for sharing
michael let's continue guys so a couple
other things here
so let me just get right into this fda
fda warns you
to not eat those foods sold at walmart
and target oh [ __ ] fta now watch this oh
[ __ ]
first it was onions they said don't buy
the onions
then it's frozen shrimp i'm good and
then even some popular prepared
meals that you can easily grab on the go
at some of your favorite grocery stores
now the fda food and drug administration
has sounded the alarm
that yet another common food is linked
to multi-state outbreak of
salmonella peaches so i said you like
peaches
okay i know you're a peach guy okay
you're always talking about peach cake
you're from miami you're a peach guy you
know i'm like this guy
oranges tangerine yeah yeah so maybe you
got to read into that joke but according
to the fda you should not eat or serve
any loose or bagged peaches that were
packed
or supplied by prime wawona or wanna
packing company from june 1st to august
3rd
the same goes for its bagged wawona
wawana organic peaches distributed and
sold
from june 1st through august 19. a
recent cdc food safe anyways
so here's a question i got for you so
these things come out i just shared it
with you i'm actually curious for the
viewers that are listening to this
i just share this with you is this luis
ken sam kai is this gonna ch if you
how many guests you buy peaches who buys
peaches you buy peaches
is it gonna change your mind about
buying peaches are you still gonna buy
peaches at walmart or target
i just read this to you are you gonna
say you know what i'm gonna skip on the
peaches for a couple months
well i actually just recently bought
peaches there yeah so now you're
thinking about it now i'm like
oh my god i just bought a bag of peaches
i didn't buy a bag i just bought the
fresh loose but i'm not even sure if
those are even safe right so
hearing this it kind of worries me does
it worry you it worries me a little bit
because
not pregnant wife that's pregnant she's
pregnant luis happy wife happy life
all right you take that with you so i
might i might need to consider where i
buy my pieces
yeah you know a lot of people are saying
i love peaches
i didn't hear about this it doesn't
change my position
stop buying food at target i'm still
buying at costco
so i don't know i don't know you know
because these things come out all the
time you said i'm still buying peaches
i'm still buying peaches let's see who
says i'm still buying peaches i'm still
buying peaches like costco instead
uh that is javier0304 javier don't give
a [ __ ] he's
i'm buying my peaches i don't care what
you say pat i'm a peach guy well
i just i just wonder if this actually
works when they come out saying things
like this like do you see a 22
drop off on peach sales the following
week at a place when
kai i'm wondering if it's been since
june they say
but they said june 1st through august
3rd
june 1st through august you don't care
like right now at this point but how do
you know it's not going to happen on
august 21st or august 28th you know what
i mean like
how did they come out with this
measurement or is it or is it a war
against peaches like
they had a bad deal behind closed doors
peaches didn't give them a bonus and
they're like you know what night after
watch what we're gonna
do we're gonna ban peaches at walmart
here's the bigger question pat
i'd love to get people's perspective on
the room the as of date
all right don't eat this you know as of
date you know august 27th that's the
date
did can you can you go to the 28th can
you go to the 30th you can always use
the smell test
you do the smell test i do the smell
test for maybe that works for milk
it doesn't work for peaches though per
se i do the smell test for a lot of
things i go out there i just look at the
i look at the
you know turkey and i'm like yeah i
don't know about this
week away you know like almond milk you
can buy almond milk a milk and almond
milk can be good for by the way six
seven eight months wow yeah very
different than my regular
meal you can buy almond milk it can sit
there for a long time and you're good
right
even when it's open yeah it's pretty
interesting so you don't go by the as of
date you do by the smell test
i i so so our nanny this woman is
so unique she loves melva's amazing
she's one of a kind
she keeps she's a what do you call it a
hoarder like a
you know order yeah if i if we go to a
restaurant i'm done
yeah no daddy we take that i said mom
i'm good i'm telling you i don't want to
no no we're taking that i'm not taking
this
i take it for me i take it i take bring
box she takes it
so in our by the way melva speaks
perfect english i don't know why you're
making that accent
she speaks english so she you know so
so then we'll go and we'll but she does
that but some you know for me
you know it's uh uh you'll see some of
the stuff that it doesn't smell that bad
you go ahead and eat it
what about you rapper tony yeah i think
it's the words you know
words have meaning so if it's you know
as of
date yeah um i i won't touch it and i
don't do the smell test
don't do this but if it's best if used
by
then it's kind of just more of a
suggestion as of is different than best
you know i think so i think so so why
don't we do this why don't we mix this
up and and
ask the question from all of you guys
what was special about nostradamus what
made him so special what could he do
nostradamus
what was he known for the future he
could predict the situation
okay who is the modern day nostradamus
well dave chappelle was once negro
dominus he played that uh on his
character so that's the mind that's
who's coming to mind comedy but for you
okay sorry but tell me who is the
modern-day nostradamus that can make
predictions
10 years before and it becomes a reality
who's the modern-day nostradamus
these are two intelligent street types
of people i'm sitting in front of you
you may not have a four-year degree or
an eight-year degree but you got to
eight your degree in the street so
tell us who is the modern day
nostradamus
that's a tough one that's a tough one
it's a tough one by the way what do you
guys think zamaru and they nostradam
let's see if you're going to get it
right of simpsons
creator of simpsons
200 he gets it good for him he's the
winner put up put on the video by the
way
when you watch this video when you watch
this video i want to see your reaction
because this
absolutely is insane when you watch this
this video should be shared i don't know
why it's not in other platforms but
watch what they say
here go ahead and play
on november 21st 2010 conclave of
america's media empires
we are here to come up with the next
phony baloney crisis to put americans
back where they've been
in dark rooms glued to their televisions
too terrified to skip the commercials
well i think nbc you are here to listen
and not speak
i think we should go with a good
old-fashioned public health scare
a new disease no one's immune it's like
the summer of the shark except instead
of a shark it's an epidemic and instead
of summer it's all the time
now i hate to be the guy who derails
what everybody else loves he loves being
that guy
but janice we do have standards this
can't be a made-up disease
the only moral thing to do is release a
deadly virus into the general public
we do have something we've been holding
on to but it hasn't been tested
[Music]
i'd like to call the order this secret
conclave what do you think about that
that's ten years ago by the way is is
that so so
if you watch this it's one of few things
hang on let me give you
the options one
they're just you know prophesizing and
they're just kind of throwing it out
there's a good story to make
number two they know something the
writer is connected to
cia somebody that's a family member that
we don't know about
number three is they're being fed this
number four pure luck number five
it happens all the time it's the truth i
mean what do you think this is
man that's uh number one the i've seen
other simpsons things
maybe they've predicted in the future
this is one of them number one trump
they predicted
i've seen that before um i think they're
just that talented
you don't underestimate creative
thinkers i mean they they're
they're coming up they're sitting up
concocting all sorts of
who knows what's coming out of their
head that's one option number two
uh matt groening the creator of simpsons
more than likely was in a wet market in
china and created the wuhan virus that's
another option i've heard
people are saying that people are saying
that i don't know who it is but people
are saying that that's an option
but it's uh it's really impressive stuff
what they do out there i don't know
what do you think michael oh it just
keeps creeps me out does it really creep
you out there yeah it creeps me out i
mean you know i've seen
again a bunch of you know predictions
you know
you know i don't know i mean is it one
of those kind of things that there's
just so many shows
that they just write show after show
it's just kind of a coincidence but they
just seem kind of dead on though
yeah for that to be that that that right
there is creepy that's 10 years ago you
see something like that
i wonder what was going on 10 years ago
at that point well
what kind of virus was going on obama
dealt with one virus at that time
you know but to say release it release
it
i mean that's a that's a different story
right there but also look at i mean some
of these
futuristic type movies they're thinking
you know the avatars of the world
and the star wars of the world it's like
in 1984 yeah
and like in 1984 or like the end of the
world or all these end of times movies
so what you're saying
they're looking into the future being
like let's just think of the worst case
let me ask you a question
what's going to scare the [ __ ] out of
people you're trying to say tonight yeah
when you go to bed
and your left leg is off to bed yeah
you're not going to be worried that
a monster under the bed is going to pull
your leg you're going to leave it the
way it is
or are you going to do the right thing
and put the leg under the covers what
are you going to do tonight is this
going to freak you out a little bit
sometimes there's alligators or sharks
on the uh uh
there's no question about it yeah
there's no question no question about
boogeyman's outside book
is out there so that that's it that's
not a big deal it's just a show
he's coming forward yeah i don't think
nothing more nothing less
i mean what do you think you got to have
i mean if you're going to play the
simpsons thing you got to have a pretty
star
this is the one place where if you say
what's your point i don't have a point
here
i'm just one just wanted to put it out
i'm just wondering what public but this
isn't the first time though these guys
have done a lot of different things
there was even a kobe one that was made
by a completely different
uh cartoon i mean these cartoon folks
you know there's something with them
i i i uh like you said about the level
of creativity but
uh to to look at this one current today
is this what could have been used to
have somebody like trump that cannot be
bought to say let's do this
i don't know when i interviewed with
this guy john perkins i tell you
everything changed from when i sat down
with john perkins
the characters like john perkins you
only heard about in movies okay economic
hitman yeah tell me about this guy
you haven't seen this okay so john's
seen this one so john perkins this just
comes out this came out uh uh two months
ago
john perkins job as an economic hit man
okay
what he did he would go to different
prime ministers around the world where
america wanted
their natural resource aka oil
they would go to and they would say we
need you to agree
to get this loan from us for four
billion dollars
the company we're gonna give them the
four billion dollars to invest
and create a plant in your country and
create jobs
this is going to help with your economy
to create jobs
then they do the deal and he would say
if you don't agree to this
don't forget what happened to the leader
of vietnam and don't forget what
happened to the leader of this place
they both died i'm just telling you i'm
representing the u.s government that
sounds like some mafia
so then you say yes he says everybody
would pretty much say yes only two
people said no and they're no longer
with us
everybody who said yes they would come
and the moment the government can no
longer make the loan payment
then they would take over the uh uh the
company
and then they would say now you owe us
money give us the oil give us this
and they would buy and they would say
we're gonna take care of your kids we'll
put them in harvard we'll put them in yo
whatever school
we don't care what their grades are we
put them in the best schools in america
they can come out of you we'll pay your
wife a million dollar your income don't
worry about it we'll pay all this other
stuff but you have to agree to do this
he says almost everybody would agree to
it right economic hit man
are there other forms of economic hitman
i was having a conversation with a
can i say his name i cannot say his name
i want to say his name i can't say his
name one of the most powerful
people in the iran community okay
had a call with him this week last week
i had a call with them today's what
tuesday
last friday he and i had a zoom together
which by the way zoom zoom took a hit
yesterday i don't know if you guys heard
about that we'll get to that
so i had a call with them uh last week
and
we talked about what's going on with
iran and this person
didn't want to do an interview and we're
going back and forth it's one of the
uh one of the people was a famous
general
on the shah's regime 50 years ago
long story short i said you don't want
to do an interview right now iran
just is about to take 400 billion
dollars from china
you know when john kerry and obama
brokered the deal of 150 billion dollars
to iran
yeah this is three times that china is
putting 400 billion dollars in iran you
know what china's doing
they're owning iran for the next 50
years if they take this deal
so when i watch some of these things
simpson making
and you see some of the things that
china is doing and you sit there and say
i mean i don't know man i i think
there's bigger things going on you got
folks that are economic hitmen that what
they do for a living every morning they
wake up and they say
what can i do to hurt that economy and
the number one economy in the world is
who
us how do you break them apart so if you
go think about think like the darkest
person you know
a dark person divisive person evil
person
i've hired some of them and you learn
very quickly that these guys got a very
very
interesting side to them they have no
problem hurting you
they deep down inside they won't hurt
you how does if you're representing
another nation and you are a dark person
you have dark tendencies how do you
divide a country up
if you have no filters how do you do it
how would you do it
did john perkins say what countries he
was able to oh he listed all of them
what were the countries
it's it's countries you wouldn't know
about it's like african countries middle
east i mean you would know these
countries but they're not
the big 20 countries that you're like
turkey it's not those countries
but he said he would go down and these
are dictators he sat down with the chav
iran he had a meeting with the shaviran
yeah he's had meetings with all this
he's in the 70s yes but what i'm saying
to you is
say you are that matter of fact let me
even bring it simpler to you sure
say you are a sibling and your sibling
is happily married okay he's got kids
and your mom and dad
constantly compare you to your sibling
okay and you're the older sibling
so always like this oh and you just
become cain you know canaan you become
kane
to think like kane how does cain ruin
abel's life
however he can right what is how does he
do it though and the reason why i'm
going here is
you have to think like cain
to know what a cain could potentially do
to you don't think like kane because you
are kane
the book 48 laws of power when robert
greene wrote that book i don't know if
you've read the book 40 laws of power
you ever read 48 laws you read the laws
of human nature that he has but
you ever read 40 laws of power have you
guys ever read 40 laws of power
40 laws of power if you read it you've
never read it no i've never read i mean
it's it's
uh every rapper's number one it's their
bible if you think about it yeah robert
greene
when you read the book there are
sections in a book you're like this is
this is a
pretty dark book right here let me tell
you this is 40 alien type stuff
very at the highest level right wow but
he says i
wrote this for you don't know how others
could be doing this so with simpsons
is this accidental is this
intentional is this sitting there and
thinking how a cane would think
is this sitting there and thinking how
an enemy would want to divide the
greatest country in the world right now
that's created more jobs for people
around the world
is that what it is i don't know but that
cannot just be accidental to create a
cartoon like that
there's some messages behind it and
whoever's doing it more power to them
anyways how about we go into the rnc is
that cool
let's talk about that a little bit yeah
that was intentional so let's go into
the let's go
and even i want to see if you're tonight
you're by yourself will you leave your
leg
off the bed you're going to be thinking
about it tonight it'll be 11 30 right
now you're going to be like
screw this i'm picking up this select
you never know
all right so did you watch the speeches
of rnc last night did you guys get a
chance to go through something bulk of
them yeah okay
all right who who first of all i have
notes on every single one of them if
you're watching
i watch every single one of them and i
have notes on all of them
and trump i'm like come on trump a
52-minute speech but i watched all of it
and i have 25 notes from his speech i
have a bunch of notes from nikki haley's
speech
so what i'll do is i'll first turn it
over to you guys who were you most
impressed
with and who were you you know not
impressed with
i think the most impressive by far was
nikki haley okay
right i mean she's look if you if you i
mean
if we rewind i don't know if you know
for all my political friends out there i
remember
vividly because i've been i've been
following nikki haley for a while i like
smart women who you know are tough and
get things done she was the governor of
south carolina
i remember vividly four years ago she
was at
the rnc full-on embarrassed
to be there i mean we could pull up the
clip she was embarrassed to be there now
four years later
she's one of the main speakers on the
first night of the rnc
but smart sharp powerful
uh nikki haley i mean what stuck out
what did she say that she has any
specific words you have
notes on what you say that stuck i mean
i think the the common theme was
you know cancel culture um law and order
yeah you know there's different there's
there's been different themes sure in
the rnc
versus the dna the dnc was all about
covid
right uh empathy um just sort of
um pitting the two major differences
against
biden and trump this one at law and
order america first
i think you know um she she
she's got her [ __ ] together i'll give
her that i think she definitely has
aspirations
um for a presidential run and whether
that's four to eight years i think nikki
haley is definitely she's got a big
upside
she's got a very very big upset who are
you not impressed with and by the way if
you're listening to this who were you
impressed with and who were you not
impressed with
whose speech stuck out and what was it
i'm actually curious go ahead
uh i'm not a fan of nepotism uh so don
jr just kind of getting parade up there
like
you know uh he's got some as we
discussed earlier some big shoes to fill
i don't think he'll ever
get out of his father's shadow that's my
opinion i think um
his lover slash um
you know we won't we we'll we'll keep it
kimberly yeah kimberly
garfield it sounded like she was you
know
somehow she ended up speaking why is she
speaking because she's banging don jr
and
you know and she's a republican voice
although she used to be married to our
good friend out in el uh
california your best friend governor guy
great hair
that he gets his hair cut great governor
newsome yeah great guy
um yeah obviously uh
they paraded tim scott out there who
crushed it he
he he did his thing they they one
democrat vernon jones uh out of uh
um georgia came and did his thing
uh our mutual friend herschel walker
came out there he did a couple push-ups
what'd you think about what he said i've
known donald trump for 37 years he ain't
a racist
all right cool congrats like i mean if
there's people i'm gonna hear from it's
not
like that's like saying i know you have
opinions on lebron yeah
i'd rather hear from lebron who's
current and relevant these days than a
you know guy who hasn't been relevant in
30 years
herschel walker respect amazing football
player i don't necessarily
need to think what he thinks politically
especially obviously he has bias he's
been friends with donald trump for 37
years but
respect to herschel but
you know just okay how about yourself
michael and i enjoyed it i enjoyed it
i i you know mike keep trying to keep
that mic in front of you all right go
ahead
if uh you know i i saw this morning um
last week's convention it wasn't an
american flag on the on the stage
there was a dnc yeah it was just it was
so different the two vibes
there wasn't an american flag no did you
see the stage there wasn't anything on
there i don't know okay
so a lot of americans can you pull it up
the uh
and then speaking of that uh it just
seemed so dark it was like the last
country yeah last week it was
you know the country is in in turmoil
and the country is this and last night
was kind of
it was kind of a pick-me-up it kind of
kind of got me excited i
i enjoyed uh tim scott
i i enjoyed what he had to say uh they
call him token tim
yeah the uh that kim kimberly it was it
was
that was disturbing no i mean that was
just disturbing i mean actually
what were your thoughts on that yeah i
just kind of thought she was yelling at
me i kind of felt a little
you know i jumped in the shower at that
point i was like i can't take any more
rehearsal i'm just going to take a break
here
it can be taken in different ways after
you watch it you could jump in the
shower but okay yeah it was
it was a regular regular warm shower it
wasn't a cold shower
so yeah no i uh it was kind of
disturbing but i enjoy you know i
i did like the fact that um
you know donald trump made appearance
after appearance during it and i guess
that's unprecedented you know that
it's it's i guess they're usually the
last speaker and they're they're hidden
he wants to be seen but you know what
though i think we wanted to see him
you know i i think that it was important
to me to see what he was doing and
speaking off of
a uh uh you know not reading you know
and and being himself and
that's kind of what i wanted to see more
of anyway you know and and i think that
that's
you wanted to see more of what just him
being a regular you know
you want more of regular trump yeah yeah
you want more regular guy trump
you want more more uh off the cuff trump
yes absolutely i want four i want four
more years of trump for sure i don't
want four more years and let's not get
it twisted it's not going to be i don't
i'm not looking for vulgarity i'm not
looking for
oh because you're going to get that but
what else yeah you know what though i'm
willing to take the [ __ ] with the sugar
you know what i mean i mean the fact is
i mean you know things are things are
going well
you know since he's been office in
office i've made accomplishments
personally i've
watched people around me make
accomplishments you know this is
i just watched the debate between
hillary and and and
president trump last week now if
she says he's going to do this he's
going to kill the economy women are no
longer going to have rights and this and
that
a whole litany of things that uh he was
going to do
here we go four years later none of
those things happened in fact
he is actually pursuing the things that
he said that he was going to do
so you know i i don't like his delivery
i don't think i'd hang out with the guy
i think it'd be embarrassing you know
to have somebody talk like that around
me and but the fact of the matter
you know i'm not that kind of guy i'm
not going to grab somebody that doesn't
you know what i mean uh ask me to grab
them or whatever you're willing to take
the good with the bad is what you're
saying
yeah you know i mean i'm not going to
judge the guy we didn't judge cl you
know i didn't judge clinton
on the job that he was doing based on
what he was doing in the oval office i
really didn't care now a lot of people
say well if he's going to lie to the
his wife he's going to lie to me you
know and you know but
donald trump i don't think is going to
grab me i don't think you know what i'm
saying so
i think he's doing a great job so yeah i
want four more years to answer your
question yeah one more year
absolutely let's go down your list
you've got a lot of news whatever you
got what do you got so much remember dnc
we had a few key words right trust
science
all those words science by the way was
very interesting listening to uh michael
give his perspective on trump
uh as a small business owner his life
and the people around his
life got better because of president
trump so that's an interesting take
but here's the key words here's the key
words that i wrote down on
the differences between the two one was
democrats blame america for everything
okay
dnc talked about how much they despise
america
this was about dreams okay this was
about dreams dnc was about nightmare
this is all about dreams everything was
dreams dreams dreams dreams dreams
and it was different on the other side
i'll go down the aisle with every one of
them i have
uh 16 17 speakers so i'll just give you
the main highlights jim jordan talked
about uh
the democrats want to defund police
defund border patrol defund the military
we won't let you go to church
but we'll let you protest we won't let
you go to work but we'll let you riot
it's kind of interesting then he told
the story about his nephew eli
who died a few years uh uh last three i
believe
and the father's name of eli is todd and
trump calls jim jordan say how are you
doing he says how's the family doing so
we're not doing too well then jim jordan
asked would you be willing to talk to
the father for a few minutes
trump got on the phone and talked to
todd for five minutes and the family was
sitting there just to mourn together the
loss of a
child you know this kid was a prodigy
coming up with a wrestler
so jim talked about the connection side
of what he did on the family side i
thought it was powerful message
that he gave the couple who pointed guns
at the blm protesters in st
louis they spoke and i don't know if you
saw that talk or not they just got up
and they said look
you know none of us are looting outside
the house we're chart none of
it says none of the looters were charged
with a crime but we were
so let me get the straight people are
coming to my house my private property
and i'm the one that's charged with a
crime and they're not how does that make
any sense so they're protecting the
looters but they're not protecting
their citizens they talk about
pro-second amendment
we're not the kind of people that back
down neither is donald trump donald
trump brought us the best economy ever
but the democrats have brought it us
brought us nothing but distractions so
that was them good talk
safe good talk that they gave vernon
jones i thought
crushed it uh he's the guy who were
talking about the georgia democrat state
representative
he said black people are free with free
minds so he didn't like the fact that
democrats said i cannot believe you're
going to speak at the end
at the rnc and you know he says i got
letters i got threats they told me to
resign all this he says that's the thing
with the black mob
they do this just because i am rep
supporting a
president that's doing good for them he
says here's joe biden who talks about
he's going to make change he says you've
been in office for 47 years
trump's been in office for three years
you've been in office for 47 years you
had a chance to make results you have no
results
it's all talk no action great point 47
years
uh that was interesting he says if i
work hard this is he says my dad told me
hey son if you work hard treat people
fairly
there's nothing you couldn't accomplish
in your life again dreams
dreams that's the messaging right he
says trump did a
historical criminal uh justice reform
what he did uh
he spoke about police officers and he
says well you know that's so that's
vernon jones i thought it was a good
talk nikki haley
she came out and she told a story about
ambassador jean kirkpatrick
that in 1984 he gave this talk this
ambassador because she was also an
ambassador
uh nikki haley u.n right she said she
said that this ambassador during
reagan in 1984 says democrats always
blame
america first democrats always blame
america first
that's her point in the first 30 seconds
by the way when she came out there was a
couple guys that made points like that
her matt gates was right off the bat
so she made that point then she said joe
has a record of weakness and failure joe
biden is good for iran and isis great
for communist china and god sent for
anyone who wants to
who wants america america to apologize
abstain abandon our values let me say
this one more time what you said
it's a powerful line joe biden is has a
record of weakness and failure he's good
for iran and isis
great for communist china and god sent
for anyone who wants america to
apologize abstain and abandon our values
okay that's a
very strong statement she talked about
cutting taxes
we cut taxes they raised them in her
state
when we brought good jobs to south
carolina obama obama and biden sued her
her state they want to tell americans
how to think americans know how to think
democrats love telling everyone that
america is a racist nation america is
not a racist nation
then they she talk about cops cops
matter black cops matter black cops
lives matter
black small business owners lives matter
and then she went on this part
with uh progress which i thought again
she crushes she gave a very good message
it's a kind of a message that maybe four
eight years from now people gonna look
at and says who
what's the bench look like you know when
when obama gave that talk and all four
they're like listen that's a good bench
we have a guy that we can do something
around in oh wait
she's kind of getting into that league
she's both not
liked by some republicans and not liked
by some democrats which could be a good
thing
when she runs because that's kind of
like what trump had going on she's got a
similar trump card
in a different way that could work for
matt gates came out the gates firing
he said first sentence i'm speaking to
you in an
auditorium emptier than joe biden's
schedule
it's his opening line i'm speaking to
you in an auditorium
emptier than joe biden's schedule pretty
strong
opening when you say that by the way
settle for biden is a hashtag promoted
by aocn socialist let me say this one
more time
aoc and the socialists have a hashtag
that's being used on twitter i don't
even know if you know about it
it's called settle for biden settle
for biden meaning let's just settle for
biden forget about trump let's get this
guy out
but don't get it twisted aoc and the
socialists do not want bite them you saw
who
she endures the left wing wants to make
america weaker to move their agenda
forward so that was his message andrew
pollock
school safety activist gunman shot his
daughter five times and she died on
february 14 2018. this is a guy
with a lot of swagger a lot of
confidence and heartfelt you feel this
guy
and after his daughter's murder i
noticed the media wasn't interested in
the fact
so they didn't tell her story but they
told other stories
his daughter innocent daughter in school
gets her can you imagine your kid is
dice gets shot five times just because
what does she do she did nothing so he
told that story
very powerful far left democrats made
the shooting
in the school possible that's andrew
pollock donald trump jr i mean he
he was interesting to me um the one
thing that he did say that was powerful
he said the chinese communist party
prefers biden
okay which he's right he sold the dream
it was constant dream america is about
to
imagine he used the word imagine i think
10 times imagine a world where you can
live your dreams you can have that
you can have he kept saying this you can
have that i thought he did a good job
kimberly was a little bit uncomfortable
watching her
especially if you watch her on 2.0 speed
on youtube it was very difficult
watching her
uh it was it almost seemed like there's
a video of them
of donald trump jr drinking two red
bulls before the talk okay
on instagram he posted his dad shared it
it looked like
she had one too many red bulls when she
gave the talk she talked about human sex
trafficking and uh
you know in president trump's america we
like things
up is what she said in president trump's
america we like things up the market
you have to watch it okay the the the
church market all this other stuff you
know could be
taken out of context hershel walker said
what he said uh ron
ronald mcdaniel rnc chair she said i'm
the second woman 164 years to run the
rnc
and he didn't choose me because i'm a
woman he chose me because i'm qualified
to do this job second woman which is
pretty interesting that everybody says
trump doesn't support women yet the rnc
chair is a
woman it's kind of by the way somebody
called that trump the other day and says
yes
the rnc chairman is a woman and they
were shocked
most people didn't even know this that
that is the case does trump
choose the head of the rnc yes the
president chooses the head of the rnc
you did so the support has to come from
there kim klasik
baltimore this this girl's fireball
young canada baltimore's video went
viral
she crushed it again democrats assumed
that black girl black people would
constantly work for them blindly
she says we want safety in our
neighborhood lower taxes better
education better jobs and i think she's
got a
good career ahead of her maximum oliver
did a great job when you know he escaped
fidel castro and communist regime to
come over here i thought he did a
fantastic job
tim scott talked about education seven
million jobs pre-coveted
two-thirds of the jobs that trump
created out of the seven million went to
women latinos and african-american
that's just record-breaking on what he
did charlie kirk gave a good job
uh trump got up there and he talked
about the 80 million ballots right off
the bat
in the first 30 seconds what he talked
about is the ballots
his post office first thing he talked
about was that
it wasn't like he took 20 minutes you
have to know that when you're giving a
speech
you got to know your first minute's
going to be remembered whatever you say
in the minute that's what everyone's
going to watch
not a minute 51 not minute 48 minute one
he talked about
80 million ballots and they're working
post office scandals as i'm preparing
all of you
they're already talking about it because
they're talking about it's their
strategy it is a scandal
he called it the most important election
in the history of our country
he said success brings people together
it says pre-covet while everybody was
making money
401ks was good democrats were very happy
with me because success brings people
together now because of covet things
have divided so look at your 401k you
should look at your 401k
because it's doing good because the
market's back up nasdaq has broken the
record 16 times now
farmers he got them 28 billion dollars
from china november 4th everything's
going back to normal biden's comment i'd
shut down the economy if
kind of took a shot there and then he
talked about vaccine stage
three trials it's you know most people
wouldn't predict that go this far
until a few minutes ago nobody knew i
was coming last minute he decided to
come and talk because of what that state
did he campaigned there before
he called msnbc the usual msdnc dnc took
under god out of the national anthem to
their meetings that they had when they
did the
the not the national anthem the pledge
of allegiance they took
under god out it was during two meetings
it was the lgbtq
caucus meeting and the muslim delegates
assembly didn't say under god
and then they're trying to steal the
election you know rigged election bernie
sanders is the greatest loser i've ever
met
this guy's so happy you just lost what
are you happy about
bernie sanders the greatest loser ever
he says
you lost your chance to be a president
why are you smiling
china had its worst year in 67 years
which is what's happened to their
economy we now have it that the
signature doesn't have to be verified
signature doesn't have to be verified to
vote it's kind of weird
we built our wall it'll be done shortly
and he talked about some of his
accomplishments
how many judges they chose cut drug
prices first time in 51 years
can you imagine 51 years first time they
cut drug prices anyways so that's the
message he gave okay
with the the speakers that spoke there
it was
the first night to me was watching it
you were kind of like
here's here's here's the best example
i'll give you
i don't like to go to church here's why
i don't like to go to church
you'd go to church and there was pastors
who would get up
to collect money and this happened
sometimes in the army there's a big
armenian church that had a big fallen
out
and a lot of people that had money left
this church and a lot of them quite
frankly
stepped away from the religion of
christianity because of the way
that your channel thinks my friend was a
hardcore christian he converted me and
he stepped away
okay and you know what it had to do with
money but here's one of the things on
how church uses the bible
there's two ways they convert people one
of them they get get up and the pastor
says what the pastor says
if you don't give your life to christ
you're
going to hell here's what hell looks
like you ever seen these advertisements
they paint what hell looks like with
volcanoes and fire and you're going to
be burning up in hell
oh yeah and then there's the other
pastor that gets up and says listen man
you can't go to heaven let me tell you
what heaven looks like
you're going to see your family maybe
you've been away from your grandma or
your mom or your husband
you're gonna see them again this is
heaven so they're both
trying to get people to convert to go to
heaven
one is selling hell the other one is
selling heaven
dnc was selling hell rnc was selling
heaven very big difference in
perspective and the biggest churches in
the world
they tend to sell heaven right in the
heavens being sold on one side not yet i
think it's
ironic where i mean it's just very
ironic in 2016 what was donald trump
selling
he was selling hell america is the
american dream is dead
i only i can save it yeah you know it's
chaos in the streets i'm the law
order candidate four years ago he was
selling the hell version now
ironically he's selling the heaven
version i don't know about that i think
both him and obama sold a dream
i actually think both him and obama sold
a dream let me tell you
obama's speech if you've not watched
obama's speech and inauguration speech
what it was a semi mlk type of speech i
just got the chills man
you know obama's speech have you ever
seen obama have you ever heard a speech
of course it's a dream speech of course
i mean you're sitting there
republicans voted for this guy because
they sold you the dream
this is i'm not taking rnc or dnc i'm
telling you
obama won two terms because he sold the
flipping dream
george bush senior lost second term
because he sold the nightmare
and clinton sold a dream and trump is
selling the dream and biden's selling a
nightmare it's not an effective business
model this time around i totally agree
with you this time around it's not going
to work in their favor
and he was selling more of a nightmare
scenario no 2016
things that were trump was coming out of
trump's mouth is america's a [ __ ]
it's falling apart we're going to make
it great again
uh america was he was selling the fact
that why are we bowing down to our
enemies because obama went to the
middle eastern tour he bow he says why
is america bound to everybody why are we
giving all this money to china why are
we doing all this stuff
why are we not protecting ourselves
let's build a wall and protect us first
rather than protect other people
why are we going to half of these wars
we don't need to go to these wars why
are we involved in every one of these
wars
let's take care of us first that is a
form of selling the dream that is
selling the dream
it's not selling the nightmare you're
selling you're buying a dream right now
the audience right now
i'm talking to one of my former
employees uh mickey and i were having a
conversation she's a former marine
i said mickey what are you doing who you
voting for she says honestly pat i'm
undecided i'm waiting to finish watching
rnc i watch dnc and i'm watching our
she's part of ten percent ten percent
that is undecided did you know that by
the way no
ten percent as well forty two percent
for sure voting republicans hundred
percent forty six percent forty four 44
44 democrat for sure voting democrat
that's 42
44. so now we're at four percent four
percent libertarian green
shout out to joe jorgensen we know we've
got a huge george ogre community out
there
so that's 90 10 of america has no clue
what they're doing
10 you know who's part of that 10 my
grandma
my grandma she's voted for democrats
she's voted for republicans
but i respect that let me tell you i
respect that to me i respect that to
know that
you're actually watching to see what's
being said there's a part of the 42
republicans that's kind of like they're
both blind just so you know the 42 and
44.
they're both blind following it because
you know
what what a kennedy democrat is
different than what a biting democrat is
a kennedy democrat they were not bound
down to the socialists
kennedy became a president of lord of
taxes biden's saying i'm raising a taxes
and they say why are you lowering the
taxes for you to go become
rich for you to go become prosperous
use these lower taxes to protect your
family it's a different democrat today
than it was before
very different democrats i find it i
find it ironic that
obviously the reason that biden ran was
you know because he saw what trump was
doing but the other fact was
the democratic party and this is why i'm
just i
consider myself more libertarian these
days yeah is being pulled way too far to
the left
the bernie's exactly cortez is wait and
i find it ironic that bert that
biden ran because he's like look like
i'm i think we would all agree he's a
moderate he's a moderate
democrat he's not he's not a leftist
communist
so it's ironic that the democratic side
the leftists the ocasio-cortez are
basically saying
settle for biden right you know he's not
he's not as as left as we should
right so in his own party they're
basically saying that he's not two left
and then obviously the republicans are
saying socialist agenda this communist
agenda this leftist agenda
so which one is it you know you got to
decide for yourself
if you're in the ten percent you're on
the decided michael what do you think
well i'm you know my my thing with with
trump
and i'll give you an analogy um
i believe them i believe them i believe
in what they're selling i do believe in
and they're selling this dream and i
believe in the dream um i've made steps
towards
towards what they're what they're
promoting
and it's kind of i always go back to two
and a half years ago i fell in love with
my wife
i wanted i fell in love at 50 years old
with a woman
that changed my life completely
on a daily basis i wanted everyone
to feel that and i believe donald trump
wants everyone to feel successful have
money
eat provide for their children i i
really truly believe that i don't beli i
i i believe that he's a patriot
i believe that uh he's saying just get
the work in i mean yeah i mean you know
people say well you know he started with
a loan from his dad it doesn't matter
it really doesn't matter whether you
start with one dollar or 10 million
dollars it really doesn't matter get to
work in
you know and and i think that's kind of
what he's pushed me to do
my family to do um i've got a whole
house full of people that uh you know
kind of dig them too and are taking
advantage of the things that
you know we're able to today and and i'm
worried about the other side
i am i'm worried about the other side i
think that i think it's a slippery slope
um you know i i you know for me trust is
everything
you know and and uh i don't trust either
side but i feel like i trust
trump i agree with you i do think that
trump
wants um you to succeed i think he wants
you to do well
i think he wants you to prosper but
there's an if with that mr rappatoni
if you like him if you say nice things
about him
if you agree with him now if you say not
so nice things about him
or don't agree with him he don't give
two [ __ ] about you and that's the
problem with donald trump is that he
plays
to his base he plays to his base he
plays this
42 differences with the other side i'm
not saying
the other side is better but we're
talking about trump tell me you tell me
who obama liked that didn't like him
i'm just you tell me how often he went
so here's the dip but
when you say something like that you
have to have credence behind it because
here's how you got to think about it
am i wrong though i got trump 100 you're
right i'm with you
so i am right about trump but wait a
minute but you cannot say that but you
cannot say that
and only give it from one side meaning
do you think if anderson cooper
interview
invited trump to be a guest on uh cnn do
you think trump shows up
i think he would you think if bill bill
o'reilly
on his second term invited obama you
think obama shows up i don't think obama
of course he doesn't
why not though do you think trump likes
the company how many times do you think
hillary clinton sat down with hannity or
o'reilly or
no no no why not though why not i
totally hear you oh why not
they don't want the confrontation they
don't want to be called out because i
want to save so
because what you just said even though
it's true
it's a hundred times more true on the
other side
because at least trump will sit with hbo
and say
call my ass out any questions you want
there is no way in the world you can do
with the other side
you have to sit there with the other
side 88 questions you cannot ask me
92 topics you cannot bring [ __ ] i
will say that
is trump says dude ask me anything you
want
do you realize like to me i'm a i'm a
guy i didn't
grow up in the right side i'm a guy that
says hey
you know what i respect that of course
everybody wants to be liked
you know of course everybody wants to be
in an environment that they feel
better in you want to go to dinner with
people like listen a big part of right
now i'm choosing the board for the field
i have a very big decision i have to
make right now i have to make the
decision on
the people that are going to be making
the decisions for the future of the
company i'm choosing choosing a field
advisory board right now okay
guess what's one of my biggest factors
that i'm looking at they love the
company
they're 100 line with the company
they're performing they're in the game
today they're growing the company today
and you know what's one of them that
they all get along
meaning not they all agree i didn't say
agree that they get along
that they trust each other you naturally
are like that
every one of us is naturally like that i
don't think that's the differentiator
let me tell you what's one of the
biggest concerns for me
and and this is above anything else i
will vote for
i know it's going to sound weird when i
say this to you and maybe it won't sound
weird to you
if you're too easy on china you're not
getting my vote
if if if on the left
if the left had a candidate that came
out and campaigned
against china a hundred percent we
cannot trust these folks etc
cetera and that person had a track
record of pushing it
and the right came out defending china
in today's market
i'm probably voting left let me say that
one more time to you
if somebody came out that is against
china and the right is for china i'm
listening to this candidate
people are underestimating the i don't i
is that your number one buddy 400
billion dollars china's investing into
iran
what the hell are you investing 400
billion dollars into your round four 15
billion dollars into armenia
billions of dollars into africa what are
you doing what are you doing it for
what's your intention trying to take
over the world you know
you know how much property they bought
here in texas what are you doing
what's your motive what do you think
their motivation what do you think their
motive is made in china 2025 they've
casted their vision they've told the
world what their motive is we want to
take over the world we want to be bigger
that's the number one
uh agenda that you would vote for is
number one oh
i i uh you have you can never
underestimate an enemy
never never never under
i can say comfortably us has never had a
bigger enemy
than china not russia us has never had a
bigger enemy than
china no way economically you're saying
listen russia you know economically
here's who russia was
russia was the one that if you got into
a street fight guess who's going to beat
you you're russia
who would beat you who would beat you if
if russia was a human being in the 80s
remember drago if he can change i can
change we can all you know rocky
okay if if if russia was a man
yeah and us was a man and they had a
fist fight who wins in the 80s
fist fight america no way
no way no way come on buddy there's no
way america you know why russia would
win
why is it because russia will be brought
up
they'd be the wrestler that comes in
with a chair hits you with the chair but
but the point
is that you got to respect about russia
they will tell you we're going to hit
you at the head with the glass
they're going to i'm going to use the
baseball bat i swear to god i mean look
at look at the uh dissident in russia
the uh the other they got poisoned the
other day
right that that's they're going to
poison by the way they validated it
yesterday
there is a part of it that for me is an
honest
relationship but china's not like that
china is the one that gets a street
fight they're going to be like
yes no problem yeah it's okay no no we
don't want to fight
we don't want to fight but guess what
they send six people to your house
already
that that's how so if if the 10 percent
is listening to this
you know we got sick we got 16 19 but is
that a high is that's an all-time high
we got 16 19 right now
uh and i wasn't even paying attention to
it by the way first thumbs up if you
enjoyed this and share it as we're going
through it here we got last
20 minutes here we got all we're giving
out three haircuts to somebody cause
somebody's gotta get a free haircut
how about this the first first two that
come to your shop get a free haircut is
that good with that sure
first two people that go to rapper
tony's barbershop but you can get a free
haircut but you got to buy the rapper
tony shirt i don't want to do that
so if you give me that shirt i still
want to go back to this china topic
i still want to go back to this china
topic if somebody goes to rapper tony's
barbershop in plano
he's an east plano you buy one of these
shirts it's 20 bucks i wore this on the
last podcast
he'll give you a free haircut uh okay
let's get back to it so let's get back
to it
back to china back to china so just to
recap what you said one is aggressive
and one is passive aggressive you do not
mess with passive aggressive man let me
tell you
you don't i mean look tic tock's now
suing u.s okay
they're suing trump you know you're
seeing some of this stuff these guys are
doing
look look at lebron james and goodyear
can you pull up this article for me
please
look at lebron james
china owns the first time in my life as
a laker fan that i'm not rooting for the
lakers simply because of lebron james
never in my life have i said this you
got portland going to the finals
i don't have portland gold you got to
find western gods of government no i i
don't have portland going to the finals
but i do have clippers going to the
finals okay
go to the article lebron james come on
let me read the top let me
go download
oh my gosh buddy i can't read the domain
right there
lebron james china comments dragged up
in a donald trump goodyear boycott
so somebody comes out and says
you know what they say about goodyear
lebron turns around and says we don't
bend
and we don't break for nobody calling
out to trump because goodyear is based
out of where
ohio i'm an akron kid now go to the
bottom and look at the tweet that he
gets back from will kane
accept the chinese communist party
meaning we don't ban fold or break for
nobody except for the chinese communist
party yeah you ever heard
lebron say one bad thing about china you
ever heard anybody
say anything bad about china look we
heard one person not from him
no we heard one person what happened
he told to shut his mouth what happened
to him yeah he was he got crucified yeah
of course
by the way and then adam silver two
years later agreed with them but not in
that moment even steve cru disagreed
with them
even lebron james disagreed with them
there's a lot of double standard going
on in the nba regarding
the double standard part i don't worry
about lebron james and the nba they do
what they do he's making his money
good for the james family i think to be
honest with you
the level of respect i have for him as a
person who went from the streets no
father figure the mother
you know for him to become who he's
become you don't have dirt on lebron
he's done a great job for himself
that part i got a lot of respect for
what he's done he's a great example for
other people that want to follow
stay clean do that great husband family
guys super taco tuesday
all of that i'm not talking about nba
nba is irrelevant in this topic
what is relevant is the fact that the
nba is afraid of china
why is he gonna be afraid of china why
because china comes down to money
doesn't it why are you afraid of china
so look at the amount of power china has
where china says don't worry
we're going to win all your people
because we got 1.5 billion people here
and every one of them can be bought
because we have eyeballs
it's okay so if the american people are
listening to this
and some of you guys that are listening
to this you're not a republican
you're not a democrat and by the way you
know you know what i mean when some
people say
i'm a republican but they hate trump i
hate though you know when people go on
that angle and
yeah i had a person here that was
working me saying i'm a republican i
said when's the last time he voted
republican
20 years ago you're not a republican
you're a democrat you just forgot to
change to democrat
you know how people say i'm a democrat
but they haven't voted democrat for 20
years
listen man you're a republican you just
haven't changed yourself
i'm truly talking to people that can be
persuaded
if you can be persuaded you have to ask
yourself who's the number one enemy
and which side supports the number one
enemy whichever side is afraid of the
number one enemy
you better vote based on that because
the number one enemy just put 400
billion dollars in iran
and they're wanting to go into a lot of
different industries let me know i'm not
going to
because obviously you've got major
stance on china when did china
officially become the number one enemy
of the united states
was it two years ago was it 10 years ago
20 years ago
how long has it been going on well based
on who says you know based on
based on what based on what is being
said or based on quietly they've been
building themselves up based on
quietly when the 08 olympics i think it
was oil olympics in china when they
showed up and everybody's like oh my
gosh it's the greatest opening ceremony
i've ever seen
they are so competitive so competitive
so competitive but nobody knew how
dark they were and how bad they could
get
and how manipulative they're willing to
get you cannot
you cannot underestimate the power of
what they have anyways let's continue
what we have right now let's talk about
some business toys r us how about this
toys r us wants to partner around amazon
so let me get this straight amazon puts
you out of business now you want to
partner up with them
nearly three years after toys r us
blamed amazon for his dramatic downfall
the recently resuscitated toy brand is
now leaning on the ecommerce giant to
support it online it's online orders
the website was first launched in
october of 2019 as part of a joint
venture with target
now they want to work with amazon amazon
will now serve as a primary fulfillment
partner for orders
placed through the toys r us website do
you think
this is going to work and if yes why
here's what i think and then i'll ask
you guys
i think models like this
and i told you guys kind of briefly
yesterday toys r us on amazon
why would toys r us make this work for
one reason
if toys r us brought new executives that
weren't there
that got screwed with amazon they don't
care about it because they're not
emotionally tied to
the rejection that amazon gave them when
they put them out of business
but if toys r us has the same executive
team there's no way this is going to
work because pride's going to get in the
way so sometimes these things can work
to bring them back up but do you think
this can work with toys r us and amazon
of them going back to them yes no what
do you think it comes down to new
leadership is basically i think it's new
leadership
you know what do i think about toys r us
pat
i don't want to grow up but even if i
did
i'd always be a toys r us kid would you
be i always would be i mean i it's so
funny you say that and i went straight
to toys r us yeah
i don't want to grow up but even if i
did
i'd always be a toys r us kid thank you
commercials
i mean are you kidding me we're talking
about iconic commercials like you don't
think it's going away
i mean what what other toy brands are
out there these days i know there's like
the one little kid that makes like 50
billion a year just uh
scotty's toy shop or timmy's toolbox
what's the kids name whatever it is i'm
sure your kids love them
but who's the who's the number one brand
for toys these days
you know it kind of hurt my heart a
little bit when toys r us
went away what was that about two years
ago a couple years ago
i would do you want to see them come
back or do you i would love to see them
come back so we got the emotional style
yeah
can we buy him a toy afterwards
joey the giraffe toy already logically i
don't want it's gonna work
i think i don't know the mechanics
behind it i don't know what's going on
with amazon we're going to target
i'm saying on an emotional level you
know i don't have kids
jj biscuit just said don't make me sad
sam he's crying because he misses those
days i know
what do you think you know i love the
idea i love the idea i think i think
it's gonna uh i think it's gonna be
successful
um i would rather if i was gonna go buy
toys and i do a ton
of amazon shopping and uh i i actually
i would prefer to go buy toys it on a
toys r us website if they're
if their software is right and and it's
going to be the you know the ease of
purchase yeah
i think it's going to do amazing i love
that they attach themselves to amazon
because why not
if you're this little guy they're just
going to put on them by the way
what's not good for them for setting
aside ego that's not easy to do yeah
right setting aside ego they have no
other choice they're going out they're
out of business
not easy buddy it's not easy hey you
want to make zero dollars or you want to
split
a hundred billion dollars whatever the
number the guy that comes
whoops your ass and takes your wife away
from you and you say let's go out today
partner up with him let's start a
business together or do you want to just
stay homeless and live by
yourself and not have anything anybody
do that would you do that
guys something is better than nothing
the hell out of you don't get it
your what's out there valuators i'll
tell you what i got
here don't get any freaking thoughts
however something's better than nothing
right now they got no revenue they got
nothing going on
okay and when they grow up even when
they did
but if you always be a rapper only kid
if you keep the
wife out of it because i think it gets
really personal there but if you just
got
if you just get your ass kicked in the
school yard the guy's just bigger and
he'll keep the wife out of here
keep the wives out of
i think that's my line but other than
that i think i would team up with the
big guy that just gave me the beating of
my life yeah
you know you just whooped your ass all
right you taught me a beat
you gave me a beat and you taught me a
lesson let's make some money together
michael adams says pat
please give me your take on tesla
michael i did at the beginning five ten
minutes you may want to watch it it'll
be a new hot shot yeah we do cover about
cover that okay
ten minutes we got ten minutes to cover
two topics can we do that ten minutes to
two topics
one of them i want to cover is kellyanne
conway resigning okay because i think
this is good for you
to say a couple thoughts what's the
second one kellyanne uh i don't know we
can do luca we can do luca
why are you avoiding the big one why are
you avoiding the [ __ ] i don't really
care which one you want to touch up
or democratic presidents better for the
economy we can talk about that as well
okay okay but let's do kellyanne county
this is yours
kellyanne conway benefits you by the way
what are you tripping about this is
i'm not tripping i'm just saying that so
we've got a whole page on that
bro i got 50 topics i haven't touched
mike trout's rookie card sold for 3.9
million dollars
i'm a baseball card and i'm not even
going there so but tell me what you
think and by the way frank colada died
rest in peace frank colada a few million
views with us when we did the interview
with them but
kellyanne conway resigning okay split
house
challenges daughter kai i don't know if
you have the video of her going live or
not if you do
it's on youtube if you can pull that up
how big of a deal is this for trump
how big of a deal is this a big hit
losing kellyanne conway oh i think it's
a huge hit
she was telling us she would come out
there and what was her famous line
alternative facts
it's alternative facts we got our own
alternative facts going on over here
it as much as i would cringe
when she would come on tv we all would
hope
to have someone blindly follow you and
just
do whatever you do your biddings that
kellyanne conway did for trump
now what's the catch with kellyanne
conway what's the big catch well her
husband was the most
outspoken critic yeah of donald trump
george conway conservative
legal scholar he started what was it
called the lincoln
project what's the link republicans
against him against trump okay there's
there's more republicans against trump
these days than democrats against trump
you're going to find out november 4th oh
we're going to find out all right
but imagine that household for the last
three four years imagine that household
where you have the biggest supporter of
donald trump kellyanne conway
you know whether that was a paid support
or actual real life support we'll find
out
because she definitely got paid i mean
she was power's a hell of a thing
she's out there being the spokesperson i
don't know if showed us a big kid
huge hit and then you got george conway
out there i mean
we talk about how does that work how
does that work in the bedroom how does
that work in the boardroom how does that
work out good in the bedroom by the way
thank you you know what you freaking
hear me yes
what do you think man you know i i i've
never heard her say anything that i
understood
you know that was i mean she double time
every time i watched it i was i was also
what the hell did she just heard of the
fact
i felt i felt it felt personal i felt a
little violated i was like what the hell
i i understood the question violated
what do you mean she's defending your
boy what are you doing
no i just didn't understand the answer
like i understood the question and
i never understood any of the answers
you know so she did uh
political hopscotch and if that's what
trump needs i don't think it's going to
be a big hit i think that uh i i think i
i like this uh
kelly uh kellyanne mcinney oh
man yeah she's she does she's always
she's not so bad to look i
am she's not i i like i i
i follow every thing she says so i'm not
confused as she goes through you know
what i mean so i
don't know i don't i you know i don't
think kellyanne i think it's a bigger
deal than people think it is i think
okay i think because i think kellyanne
conway is a beast she's a pit bull
she's a pit bull and she's scary
and she scared the hell out of everybody
on the left because they hated having
her on and they never got under her skin
and she kept herself together but watch
what happened here in the family this
should kind of give you an idea what's
going on that household
that's that's her daughter in the house
going live now baby
no i'm not okay thanks guys though oh so
she keeps insulting my mental health
i'm just like this is just i'm just
showing everyone the truth like you're
literally not letting me
use my freedoms your daughter goes live
in the house i just want you to shut it
down because
not everybody's following you as well
meaning okay anne
hi there stop trying to unfortunately
this many people have nothing to do that
is amazing it's so nice out
oh my god mine what are you doing
here okay they got some family drama
going on over there
but you know what man again it goes back
to dividing families i don't like seeing
this stuff because that family needs to
keep their stuff in their household no
one and
if one of my kids went live and started
showing what we do in the family
household
go get a damn apartment you're 18 years
old
17 years old give me your phone you
ain't paying for the bills
that's my phone now you ain't got a
phone you do something like that in my
household
big problem she's 15 how old is she if
you're you got two rules you're under 18
give me your stuff everything car keys
everything is mine your door can no
longer be locked i take every lock off
your door that's what we're doing
if you're 18 go get a place sorry you
can't live here anymore no
you don't i think she applied for what's
the the terminology when you uh that's
the patient what is it emancipation is
it the emancipation that she no longer
has to be uh
living under the parent's roof but
that's got to be a tough situation where
you have one person that's so outspoken
in favor of trump
and one person that's so outside for
mommy though but listen
you know what it comes down to in my
opinion she's 15 years old
yeah you know what they say is if when
you're young and you don't vote for a
democrat you have no heart and if you do
if you and if you grow up right if you
don't yeah vote for a republican you got
no brain that whole thing yeah
she's 15 years old what kind of [ __ ] do
you think she's getting in school your
mom did this
your mom's a pizza whatever my my
parents said that you're my you know
what kind of crap she's probably getting
in school
it's probably not pretty for that 15
year old daughter i don't disagree yeah
i don't know
leaking into the household but i don't
disagree but you got to realize man
blood is blood it's family
you you protect family you don't you the
one thing with the kids man if i see
anybody coming in between the kids
there's a problem there what are you
doing
it's your brother right there i tell my
boys you guys matter more to each other
than i do
you guys are going to be in each other's
lives and i'm going to be in your life
you guys better be better
better to each other than you are to me
yeah this is your brother this is your
sister you guys
better respect one another i don't
tolerate any of that stuff so
when you when you see some of this stuff
that's taking place i'm i'm i'm i'm
uncomfortable even watching
you you've got to understand that you
were raised right and you
i mean you've had a she doesn't seem
like somebody that wouldn't raise their
kids right
i mean no i don't think i think there's
a i think there's a uh
spirit of division that's getting the
best of america remember kane remember
kane
do you remember kanan if you were mccain
no cain and abel if you could think
like kane if you could think like kane
what would you do you would divide
families apart let's go to luca
luco's playing basketball okay clippers
forward
montreal's herald apologize to luca for
calling the math star
a bitch-ass white boy while they play
the game okay and they were fine again
into each other's face and the next
thing he apologized yeah
the nba doesn't suspend or do anything
now here's a question
if if luca called
harold the n-word what does the nba do
so you got
bitch-ass white boy versus n word
[ __ ] ass white boy doesn't get you
suspended what does the n word do to
luca if he did that in the playoffs
i don't know i'm i'm actually asking
inward you're that you're i mean talk
about cancel call would you be suspended
would you be suspended for sure for sure
how many games
uh you use the n-word in an nba white
guy toward not a
not a black to black he didn't okay
white white guy two black guy
oh yeah you're suspended for sure okay
what do you think about this you played
basketball before yeah
how is this is this you know normal
stuff where
it's okay both ways or it's not
acceptable okay so number one i've
played basketball my whole life i played
high school i played a little bit in
college a little bit of semi-pro i
played
do you know how many times i've been
called a bitch-ass white boy how many
times
infinite infinite amount to the point
where it just rolls off my skin
and i would beat black guys all the time
and i would be like what is up buddy you
know check ball you know no big deal
but unfortunately it is par it is a
double
standard a white guy you know a lot of
times when i would play i mean i would
play in downtown miami and i would
sometimes be the only white guy on the
court
and if a white goes yeah if a black guy
is like all right like i got the white
boy
you know it's par for the course
there's no way in hell that i'm going to
come out like all right i got the the
bitch-ass black guy i might
like you don't even say that you're not
looking for drama
there is a double standard it is what it
is unfortunately
but now in today's climate in today's
culture where blm
there's literally black lives matter on
the on the court
you know you've got riots you've got ray
yeah it's so much drama going on
everything is so heightened everything
is so
hyper sensitive you just can't say [ __ ]
like that
on tv mantras harold now if you go to
any public park
yeah any any hoop any court i guarantee
you
that is being said non-stop [ __ ] ass
white boy this that the other
and you know what i don't even know if
it's that racist i think it's just part
of
just kind of part of the basketball
culture unfortunately but
i think it took something like this for
people to be like hold on
oh black guys can say it but white guys
can't but maybe not it's not
so you know you saw what jason williams
the former duke point guard said about
it he came out and he says
damn tres like damn my tres this this
ain't cool they think you can't be doing
stuff like that
so good for him yeah no no that guy
that guy's a sharp dude right there um
if you want if you want to if you want
to play that's how good
it's it's how long is that buck 52 we
don't have that kind of time
so first of all what do you think about
that is it in the first 10 first 10
seconds play the first 10 seconds
but damn tres damn mantras
i can only imagine if luka doncic had
said something like that to you
and it got caught on tape
i can only imagine during black lives
matter how much of a big deal
that would have been considering today's
climate
and state good voice of reason right
there is
okay good for him michael what do you
think no and you know it
with what we're going through right now
i mean you know we keep pointing out
differences
you know if we just stop pointing out
the differences i don't think we're
going to have it i think it was way off
and i think something needs to be done
about it because the fact of the matter
is you're talking about it happens on
the basketball court
basketball court is a bunch of imitation
of what happens on the professional
basketball court
you know what i mean because that's when
you're playing the game it's what you
want to be i mean you know when you're a
kid you
you even pick a player and make
everybody call you that while you're
playing you know
so you know it's an imitation what you
see there so i think it's you know i
think he needs to be a better leader i
mean when you take that job
it comes with it so i think something
needed to be done i don't want to talk
about the double standard because
i think there's two different issues
here's what i will say here's what i
will say to bring some positivity to
this
let's see it if you want to talk about
luka doncic you know he is
he is not a bitch-ass white boy he is a
bad ass
mofo white boy that kid is bad he just
hit a game-winner over the clippers
no question there's i mean i think when
all is said and done i mean this is a
little forward thinking you know
nostradamus over here
he might be better than larry bird
at the end of his career he might be i
know you're a huge larry bird fan i know
you're a
huge larry bird fan but damn the kids
got games so respect to
lucca i know he's here in dallas doing
his damn thing let me tell you
he's a stud and good for cuban and uh in
dallas maps to have a guy like him and
you got his rookie card on i do i
actually have many of them
10 of them of the same card and luca
cards about 10 of them psa
how many mike trout rookie cards do you
have not a 3.9 million dollar one
i wouldn't pay 3.9 for that kind of but
would you pay for that i wouldn't pay
3.9 for
any of the new rookies what's up can you
give us an update on the cards that you
got it going on in the morning
i got a lot of stuff right now going on
there but we got 9 15
and we got to hit our time gang so
a couple things number one if you
haven't subscribed to the podcast click
on that subscribe button press that
little
bell you see right next to because
youtube alerts you if you have that and
it just sends it to you because some of
you guys get the text
but some of you don't so click on the
subscribe what's the biggest podcast
we've ever had most viewers
we've ever had and i'm going to put the
link below right there that says rapper
tony's
we said the first two to come to get a
free haircut as long as they buy the fur
shirt i put his instagram account if
you're on the plane or dallas area go
get a haircut with them
he's one of the best storytellers you
will ever see and uh who knows maybe in
the future we'll bring michael back i
uh it's obvious that a lot of you guys
like michael with uh his style i
challenge anybody out there to say wrap
a tony three times and not be at a smile
on your face
say it three freaking times
that's gonna put a smile on your face i
guarantee it's like beetlejuice gang
love you today was a great podcast we
will do it again next week i got a
convention this week with 16 000 people
on a virtual convention
with pitbull uh general mattis and trey
gowdy but we will let you know the dates
what are we right now looking at are we
looking at next wednesday what's the
date that we're looking at is it
wednesday or tuesday or we haven't
determined that yet
we will let you know just subscribe so
you get alerted on the next one
and if you're not part of our text
distribution send us a text to three one
zero three four zero one one three two
three one zero three four zero one one
three two
we and people are saying bring him back
bring him back they like michael
okay they're like michael huh next
tuesday
eight o'clock is what the schedule is
for the next podcast
have a great week everybody bye bye bye
bye bye
macaroni
you